okay so um as you know from your
research on April 1st the Israelis
struck the Iranian Embassy in Damascus
Syria killing seven people including two
commanders this is an active War because
the embassy is considered Iranian
territory and never before has this been
done
intentionally okay and this follows um
The Killing the assassination of their
General Kasam salamani in 2020 right
this is when the Americans launched a
drone strike against him in in Baghdad
and he was really the top um one of the
top Iranian
generals and what both of these um
incidents show us is that the Americans
and the Israelis have dominance over
Iran okay so military dominance
so the first thing is they have
technology
right so te technologically America and
Israel are so much Superior to
Iran um so that there's a jet that went
from Israel and went to Damascus to car
out the strike now if you did the
research you would know that the can
Embassy is right next to the Iranian
Embassy and the um strike was so precise
that it only hit the Iranian Embassy and
didn't touch anything else okay that's a
position strike that's how powerful the
technology that the Americans and
Israelis have okay but the other thing
that's important is the idea of
intelligence so how did the Israelis
know that these commanders would be
there at that time right that's
intelligence and intelligence comes in
two forms right right there's the idea
of
human and then signals signals is
basically I can listen in on your cell
phone I can track where you go I know
where your car is right that's signals
electronic intelligence the other's
human so there are spies in the embassy
who tell the Israelis that this meeting
will happen Okay so this is
clearly military dominance that Israel
and Americans possess over Iran
um and when this strike happened um as
you know the Iranians had to respond and
this was called operation true
promise and the idea of true promise was
that um there there's a strike
package okay consisting of
drones and
missiles that hit
Israel now now what they Isel say is
that 99% of these drones and missiles
were intercepted they caused no
damage and the Israel says this shows
that our Iron Dome system is amazing
we're amazing Iran cannot touch us what
the Iranians said is that no we design
the attack to
be um harmless we want we wanted we
intentionally designed the attack so
that it would not cause that much
damage okay so who's right the the
Israelis or the
Iranians I want to make an argument to
you today that the Iranians are more
believable more
credible okay and the reason why is that
the Iranians have to be very strategic
in their response to the Americans in
and the Israelis and the reason why is
the Americans in the Israelis have
milary dominance
over Iran but just because you have
military dominance does not mean you'll
win the war okay so what I believe is
that Iran and Israel are committed to a
war and it's possible that in two years
time there will be a ground invasion of
Iran okay but it's going to take time to
build up to the ground
Invasion and but just because the
Americans and the Israelis attack Iran
does not mean they will win okay and the
reason why is that as you know from your
research in 2002 the Americans
actually tried to invade Iran okay they
had they run a simulation called the
2002 Millennium Challenge and the idea
is let's pretend that we will invade
Iran and let's see what happens so they
divide the military into two teams right
Team USA
and team
Iran now um if you know anything about
the American Military you will know that
it is the most dominant powerful
military ever to exist in human history
okay it is crazy
powerful if the entire world were were
to get together and said let's go fight
the United States the world would
lose the the United States has the most
powerful military in the entire world
okay and
Iran um it's a it's a very poor
country so the United States invaded
Iran and they wanted to see what would
happen and it turned out that who
won Iran won okay and the reason why
Iran won is the idea of asymmetrical
Warfare all right and this is a very
important idea that you must know if you
are to understand this conflict
so what is as asymmetrical Warfare all
right let's pretend that Jack and I are
enemies we hate each other and we want
to kill each other okay Jack has armor
and he has a machine gun I have nothing
okay so in most battles Jack's going to
kill me
right but let's pretend that I live in a
dark forest and it's really hard to see
in this Dark Forest but I've been living
there for de ades okay so I know Dark
Forest very very well so if Jack attacks
me in this Dark Forest then it's
possible for me to win because I can set
traps right I can play tricks on Jack
and that's the idea of asymmetrical
Warfare okay even though Jack is
superior because I'm inferior I'm forced
to be much more strategic in how I fight
against Jack okay
and so as as ascal Warfare means that as
long as you can Define the terms of
Engagement as long as you can um control
how the war is fought you will
win okay so let's look let's look at
what this means for Iran and the United
States so the United States has these
aircraft carriers
and they cost like a billion dollars
okay they're very expensive but they're
very
powerful now in a s symmetrical Warfare
what happened is Iran send its entire
Navy against this one aircraft carrier
of the United States and then what
happens the United States blows up the
entire Iranian Navy okay that's what
would happen so you don't do that okay
you do not send your Navy against an
American aircraft carrier what you do
instead is you send drones okay or drone
swarms so what they did in the
Millennium challenge was they had these
suicide bools right charging these
aircraft carriers and guess what guys if
there's a lot of them like a thousand of
them you can't stop all of them and if
one hits then your boat sinks okay does
that make sense okay this is what we
call asymmetrical Warfare now what's
important to understand is that in as as
asymmet Warfare you have to control how
much resources you use okay so for
example this aircraft CER cost a billion
dollars the Drone swarms okay a drone
maybe a
$1,000 for a real one okay but then you
have fake ones that cost
$100 $1,000 are these drones that blow
up right $100 are drones that don't blow
up right you have a th000 of
these and then you that's like $10
million
and then you have 10,000 of these and
that's another $10 million okay so it
will cost you maybe $20 million to blow
up an air a$1 billion aircraft
carrier does that make sense and this is
why Iran want would win a war because
Iran would employ as Asal Warfare Jon
SWS against the American aircraft
carriers okay and um the true promise
actually showed us that the Iranians
would probably use a strategy and the
reason why is that the total package the
strike package that thein
used um cost about 10 to $30
million but how much money did they
spend to bring down these drones did you
guys do you guys know how how how much
did it cost the
Israelis to defend themselves against
this
attack okay it was one at least one1
billion
doar okay do you understand all
right
so this is this shows us that um in a
war Iran would use AAL Warfare
and it it it and even
though Israel United States have
military dominance they may not be able
to win this war okay okay so so does
this make sense so far any
questions about
this okay that's a really good question
okay and the qu the question really is
okay listen the the Iranians will use
this asan asan IAL Warfare strategy
against the
Americans and so shouldn't the Americans
respond with more strategic thinking and
that's a great question and the answer
is the Americans would not do that why
not why is it that a Asal Warfare is so
effective against uh Empires and
dominant military Powers what's a
problem of Empires
usually what is their biggest problem
what is the Fatal
flaw okay they have too much bureaucracy
but Iran also has bureaucracy but but
the empires have a much bigger problem
okay now let's go back to the Millennium
challenge now in the first test in the
first battle Iran won against the United
States right so what did the United
States
do and do what
they they they did it again they they
did another sec they did second
simulation the second simulation what
did they
do exactly okay what the Americans said
is nope this is cheating
guys can you understand as Warfare is
cheating you cannot
cheat and then the Americans won does
that make sense okay so remember in the
first instance where you are allowed to
use Asal Warfare they one in the second
instance the Americans said no as
asymmetrical Warfare is cheating so
you're not allowed to use Asal Warfare
you must fight us directly and the
Americans
won what does this tell us about the
about the American
Military exactly thank you okay they are
inflexible empires have are inflexible
and the reason why is the idea
hubris
right if you're an Empire you
refuse to Amit your failings and
faults you become very stubborn okay so
it's back to the example of Jack has his
machine gun his armor right he comes in
the Star Force thinking like I'm
Invincible right and like everyone's
like Jack don't go into that dark Forest
it's stupid but Jack's like no I have a
machine gun I don't care
all right so that's a situation that's
why Asal Warfare is so effective because
it allows you
flexibility and
creativity and the Empire the dominant
power refuses to be flexible and
creative okay does that make sense all
right and um so the classic example of
this is Vietnam where the vietn were
clearly dominated by by The Americans
but the vs were using extremely creative
and flexible tactics against Americans
whereas the Americans insisted on their
main military Doctrine okay does that
make sense all right great okay any more
questions that was a great question
thank you uh any more questions before
we move
on okay so now I want to talk about okay
if the Iranians are going to use as Asal
Warfare what would it look like
and the answer is
this when the when the Americans
invade okay the war started before The
Invasion the Iranians must do four
things if it is to Prevail in the war
okay and this is this is what we call
the
Iran
strategy
Matrix okay um the IR Str Matrix means
that uh from now on EV do
must uh fit into the strategy Matrix
okay it must accomplish the objectives
of the Strategic Matrix so the first
thing it it must do
is unite the
population okay second thing it must do
is build
alliances the third thing is whenn
global
opinion the four fourth is
weaken the
enemy okay so in other words everything
that Iran is going to do from now until
the actual Invasion will be to
accomplish all four goals at once and it
must if it is to survive a fullscale
American Invasion okay does that make
sense all right so you have the
population what does this mean okay it
means that you win the war depending on
how much your population is willing to
resist the invasion and it turns out
that even though the Iranians right now
are divided okay there's a lot of
opposition towards the current
government in Iran um as some of you
know there have been some protests over
the past few years women protesting for
more rights in in Iran okay so there's a
lot of division in that
country but I think that most IR Ians
would resist in an invasion the reason
why is that the Iranians have a very bad
history with westerners okay so the
example is
the
1953 K okay so what happened is that um
in 1909 the British discovered oil in
Iran it was called Persia back then and
so they so they created a company called
the um Anglo Iranian petroleum company
which we now know as British Petroleum
okay
BP and the idea is that this company
would be responsible for extracting and
selling all the
oil and but unfortunately the deal was
that Iran Persia would only get 16% of
profits okay they only got 16% of
profits
so the Iranians are very upset about
this it's their oil it's their resource
but they're not getting that much money
out of it okay it's basically stealing
so for decades the Iranians have been
trying to renegotiate the deal in
1953 the democratically elected
government of Iran said to the British
listen let's do
50/50 okay that's fair 50/50 50% for us
50 50 50% for you you right that's a
fair deal and the British instead of
saying yes went to the Americans and the
British and Americans together launched
a
cout against the democratically elected
government of Iran and install a police
state called the
Sha okay the
shaw which is like the monarchy okay and
the shaw the king of of of Iran was so
brutal that he created a police state in
1979 the Iranian people
overw Asha okay and and and so uh the
Iranian people do not like the idea of
foreign Invaders coming coming in and
controlling their resource okay does
that make sense so over time as Israel
and as
America continues to be aggressive
towards Iran the population will start
to coales and fight against um the
Americans okay so that's unit the
population second is build
alliances now um Iran has two layers of
Alliance the first lay is called the
axis of resistance right which which you
um which I ask you to
research and the aess of resistance uh
includes uh the Shia mil militias in
Iraq Syria heson Lebanon Kam M and the
hthis in Yaman Okay now what's important
to understand is that this is not an
alliance that that sorry what's
important to understand is that this is
an alliance okay they agree to fight
together because they have common
interest which is
to to remain independent of American
influence okay but that but that does
not mean that Hamas hollah and hufi take
orders from Iran okay they're not
controlled by Iran Iran supports them
militarily and financially but Iran
cannot completely control their
behavior okay so the example is October
7th Kamas launched an attack against uh
Israel right which resulted in this war
and Iran says we were not involved and
is is Israel Israel says that can't be
true because you control uh Hamas right
so that's the first lar of Alli
but what Iran needs to do if it is to
win the war is also bring in uh Russia
and
China okay Russia wants the United
States to fight Iran
why yeah but true to to distract and
weaken the United States um and also to
uh move their attention away from
Ukraine right does that make sense
because Russia is about to win the war
in
Ukraine um and if there's a war in Iran
then United States will be forced to
divert resources away from Ukraine into
Iran okay um what would Russia bring to
the table Russia will probably not
deploy soldiers okay well what Russia
would do is say the United States when
you invade Iran you are not allowed to
use new Tactical nuclear weapons okay
you understand Russia would say that hey
hey hey United States if you use weapons
nuclear weapons against Iran we will we
will use nuclear weapons against you
okay so basically um Russia would limit
the military options of America in a war
which would be of tremendous benefit and
advantage to Iran does that make
sense
China needs to help Iran why what does
Iran have that China really
needs what does Iran have that China
really really needs it really needs
this Chinese economy needs
what oil
right so basically China can afford for
United States to take take over both
Iraq and Iran because then it can
control the energ energy Supply to China
does that make sense so China would
involve itself um over time in order to
make sure that it's able to obtain oil
from the Middle East China right now is
getting most of its oil from the Middle
East okay um but it will take
time
for Russia and China to get to get
themselves involved for russan trying to
to to get themselves involved in this
conflict Iran must prove two things
what are these two
things what must Iran show to China and
Russia in order to get China and Russia
involved in this
conflict if you're China and Russia
you're an investor right Why will why
will I invest in you Iran
why exactly okay so the first thing is
we will fight second thing is we will
win
okay so this will take time for Iran to
prove this to to Russia and China and
the more that Iran can show it can win
the more that China and Russia will
invest in Iran both financially and
militarily and politically okay does
that make sense okay so this will take
time and the third thing is when Global
opinion so how will Iran win Global
opinion
what's happening right now that's
helping Iran win Global opinion
basically what's happening in the world
right now that is helping Iran
win Global opinion or why is the world
becoming more supportive of
Iran what thing is happening right now
that is outraging or angering the world
uh what's happening right now what's
Israel doing right now that is outraging
the
world yeah Gaza
okay so this is really important for
Iran it must maintain the world
Spotlight on Gaza okay because what's
happening in Gaza it's basically
genocide right where the Israelis are
committed to solving the Palestinian
problem once and for all that basically
means removing the Palestinians from
Gaza they can go to Egypt they can go to
Jordan it doesn't matter okay but the
Israelis the Israelis want them out of
Gaza okay and so this will go on for
many many years and as long as the
attention is on Gaza then people will
become much more sympathetic towards
Iran over time okay if you've been
following the news about America there
have been major protests at Yale and at
Columbia and other universities about
what's happening in Gaza okay all right
um and the last is weaken the enemy okay
so what what does this mean it means
that when the United States invades Iran
two years from now six years from now
who knows but when it does so it wants
to build a large Coalition of forces
okay because then it gives because then
it gives itself legitimacy right so this
this coalition
will consist of
NATO uh Middle East countries
right um and
Israel uh Saudi Arabia many many
countries and what Iran needs to do is
create conflict and descent in this
Coalition okay and the way it does that
is by building up internal
okay does that make sense there are many
people most people in America do not
support a war against Iran and so Iran
needs to encourage this internal descent
okay it can also create conflict between
NATO and the United States okay because
obviously America will want NATO
involved in its invasion of Iran but why
would France and Germany want to involve
itself right okay does that make sense
so these are the four major goals of
Iran and it
must accomplish all four goals if it is
to survive in an invasion okay so from
now on everything that Iran does will be
to accomplish all four goals okay and
this is part of as asymmetrical Warfare
does that make sense all right now let's
look at a concrete example the concrete
example
is Operation two promise why did Iran
design operation two promise the way it
did and the answer is to accomplish all
four goals right the first is unit the
population the idea here is Iran needed
to show its population that Iran can
strike back against Israel okay so
that's the first thing build
alliances striking Israel is showing um
its allies and to China and Russia that
Iran is willing to fight
okay win Global opinion now what Iran
said is we designed the
strike to not cause damage in Israel and
the reason why is it wants to win glob
Global opinion right if it if it throws
all these missiles and Rockets at Israel
and it kills a lot of people then
there'll be a lot of people sympathetic
towards Israel so the attack was
designed Not to cause any casualties
okay does that make sense all right and
if you are an observer you think that
what Iran did was right because it's a
sense of fairness and Justice right what
Israel did was wrong it attacked an
embassy of Iran Damascus that's against
that's that that is against
international
law and Iran to save face uh to pursue
Justice thre some rockets at Israel okay
so most people think that Iran's
response was show restraint and it was a
measured response okay does that make
sense right and the last thing is weaken
the enemy why would why would this
weaken the enemy well because after Iran
attacked
Israel Israel wanted to show a strong
response Okay the reason why is that
Israel has a policy of
disproportionality so Israel is
committed to dispop disproportionality
so what does that mean it means that if
you kill one Israeli they'll come 100
they come and kill about a hundred of
you or a thousand of you okay if you
throw one rocket at them they'll throw a
thousand rockets at you and the idea
here is the Torance right to make you
afraid of Israel so you would not dare
to think to attack
Israel okay so when
Iran um attacked Israel for the first
time by the way this is the first time
that Iran has attacked Israel then
Israel was committed to a
disproportionate response who stopped
Israel from a disproportionate
response
who yes why why would the United States
say Israel do not strike back
disproportionately why why would the
United States do
that yeah okay so the United States
cannot afford right now to fight another
war and also um if the United States
were to fight a war it it would have to
do so by itself okay NATO would not
involve itself the Middle Eastern
countries like Saudi Arabia UAE Jordan
would not involve themselves either okay
so the United States had to restrain
Israel and so this is creating conflict
between Israel and United States okay so
that's why uh so in other words from a
from a military dominance perspective
operation two promise accomplish nothing
okay because you blew nothing El but
from an asymmetrical
Warfare perspective you accomplish all
your four major goals and that's why um
the Iranians claimed success and you can
make the argument that from a strategy
perspective it was a very successful
operation okay does that make sense all
right any questions about this
anything uh you want to clarify or you
don't really
understand does this make sense to
you okay so Peter asked a great question
like this war how will it affect us
we're going to United States for college
we're trying students okay and the
answer is this okay the answer is um in
war there something called Rules of
Engagement and so before they have a war
all the major parties agree on what the
rules are okay so for example you look
at the war in Ukraine
now the United States and NATO are
openly openly supplying weapons and
financing and intelligence to Ukraine
right but from the Russian Russian
perspective we allow that okay we do we
will not allow NATO to send troops to
fight with with the ukrainians but we
will allow NATO United States provide
weapons and financing okay does that
make sense that this is what we call the
Rules of Engagement the rules of
War
okay so the same thing would happen if
the United States were to invade Iran
before the actual invasion there would
be an agreement among all major parties
which would include um Iran United
States Russia China Israel about the
rules of war and and so one important
rule of war is you're not allowed to use
tactical nuclear weapons okay Iran you
may have nuclear weapons you're not to
use them United States you have nuclear
weapons Israel you have nuclear weapons
but you are not allowed to use them in
in this war okay that would be the first
uh agreement second agreement is that
Russia and China are allowed to provide
assistance in a very limited
basis okay so so China would probably
provide weapons and material but this
will not impact the relationship between
China and the uh United States okay and
during this war China will maintain a
position of what we call
Strategic ambiguity
and all this is saying is that China is
not going to say that we support Iran
okay Russia will not come out and say we
support um Iran never um before before
this war happens Russia and China could
if they choose sign a treaty with Iran
saying that if if anyone attacks you
we'll come to your Aid right they will
not sign this treaty because they need
to maintain strategic
ambiguity okay China and Russia do not
want to be dragged into this
war does that make
sense okay so uh my guess is that China
will provide assistance to Iran but on a
very limited basis and on a basis that
the United States can
accept Okay that's the first thing
second thing is listen I I'm just making
prediction that this war that that this
war will happen I don't know it's going
to happen Okay you understand I'm I'm
just High School
teacher I'm not making the the the
decisions okay I'm just teaching you how
to think about
geopolitics um and third of all when
when you actually in the United States
you'll find that there's so much anger
at Israel that no one really cares about
Chinese
students do do you understand I mean
like at that point um most Americans
will be extremely anti-war
uh it it would be like the Vietnam War
where um you have these massive you have
this um massive protest and civil unrest
because there were a lot of Americans
who were against the war and quite
honestly it was a pointless War America
accomplished Nothing by fighting
fighting the war okay okay so so so
great question Peter um does does does
that make sense to you okay any more
questions
okay great question okay so we talked
about the idea of hubris right empir
have
hubris um and so Israel is a small
nation about 8 n million people right
it's not the American Empire it's not
the American
Empire the problem is this the problem
is that if you look at the Middle East
the strongest military power in the
Middle East is Israel by far okay Israel
does not actually need American
protection if the entire Middle East got
together and attacked Israel Israel
would win because this happened twice
before right in the young K War and the
Six Day War so military speaking um
Israel is powerful and quite
honestly if the United States were to
retreat from the Middle East Israel
would
dominate okay so even though it does not
look like an Empire it's basically an
Empire you understand so therefore It
suffers
from hubris okay it's not going to be
strategic and flexible and creative it
doesn't have to be because it has
military dominance over
everyone but but but but that's a very
good question okay just because Israel
is small does not mean is weak it's very
very
powerful
okay any more questions
um okay um the question is very
interesting
so is America constraining Israel and
you can make the argument both ways okay
you can make the argument that
um um American presence in Israel is
preventing Israel from starting a
regional War okay but you can also make
the argument that is right now is using
America to pursue a lot of its
geopolitical
interests okay so um so it's a very
complicated question okay but I think
that um I personally think that America
is right now constraining
Israel okay
because Israel needs American Support
and that constrains the actions of
Israel but if America were not around
then it's possible that Israel unleashes
its the for of of its military and its
military is very very
powerful
okay right but um if America were to
lead the region then I think Israel
would become the dominant power in the
region
but um I think the same is true for
throughout the world if America left
Europe who would become the dominant
power Germany right and if America left
East Asia who who who become the
dominant
power Japan okay okay does that make
sense so I would say that the regional
Powers right now are Germany Israel and
Japan and it's a it's American Empire
that's constraining all three right now
and if America were just like to go back
home and isolate itself then these three
nations would rise to the top
okay any more
questions that's a great question okay
so um first of all I listen this is all
Theory and conjecture right America has
not expressed any intent of invading
Iran
and if America does invade Iran then
ches are it will win the war
okay but um an invasion of
Iran um it if it lose the war it would
basically mean the end of of the
American Empire okay and the reason why
is if you look at why Empire's collapsed
it's because of three reasons okay the
first is the idea of
extension
okay ere extension it's doing to things
at once okay it's fighting this war in
Ukraine it's fighting this war in Iran
it's fighting this war everywhere
basically okay the idea of overextension
that's the first reason second is the
idea of um
debt it basically just runs out of money
right because it's overextended and and
this leads to the idea of civil
unrest
okay so um the American Empire is
heading to a lot of trouble over next 10
10 years because all three things are
happening at once right overextension
debt and civil
unrest at the same time the American
Empire is extremely wealthy and
extremely powerful so even though
America loses the war there's still no
peer competitor to the United States but
all that means is that the world will
will divide into different Regional
blocks okay where maybe Germany controls
Europe uh Japan controls East Asia
Israel controls the Middle East okay so
so more of a parallel world okay a
multipolar world as opposed to a
unipolar world where one nation controls
everything the decline of the American
Empire is is is going to take decades
possibly
centuries okay but um we'll talk about
this uh
in in future class okay what what will
happen to America if it l the war okay
any more questions
yeah okay uh so that's a good question
okay like okay the ground
Invasion what what will provoke it okay
um and that's and that's something that
I want to spend a future class on okay
but um listen we've done we've done
we've done a lot of Wars okay and we
know that America doesn't really need a
reason to fight a war do you understand
it can just make them up a reason it
doesn't
care so um basically the argument that I
I want to make is that if Trump wins a
presidency then it's most likely that he
will start a war against Iran okay
that's what I think I think it will be
Trump who initiates the war and I think
that um um it will happen maybe two
years from
now so this is a very complicated
question okay like what what's
relationship between Israel and America
and the reason why it's complicated is
that um there's something called the
Israel Lobby and again we need to spend
an entire class on the idea of the
Israel Lobby because it makes no sense
okay it's really hard to understand by
itself so I'll spend an entire class on
the Israel Lobby you and then you
understand why there's an alliance
between Israel and America okay all
right but but thank you okay any more
questions so we so so just to summarize
we will do a class on Jack's question uh
what will the war look like and what
will what will mean for America if it
loses the war we'll also do a class on
David's question which is what's what's
the relationship between Israel and
America okay any more
questions we will yes we'll Al also be
talking about the rise of Japan and
Germany okay all right any more
questions okay great I I I'll see you
next week okay